ahora quiero mostrarles la ecuación de
una onda y explicarles cómo usarla pero
antes de hacerlo quiero que veamos qué
significa que una onda pueda tener una
ecuación esto es lo que significa
imaginen que tenemos una onda en el agua
que se ve así y gráfica mos la altura
vertical de esta onda de agua como una
función de su posición así que digamos
que ustedes están caminando por el
muelle y vemos que llega una onda de
agua que se dirige hacia la playa y
pueden ver que la onda se mueve así
hacia la playa y en la realidad el agua
las ondas en el océano no se ven así
pero esta es la forma matemática más
sencilla que tenemos para describir esta
onda así que vamos a comenzar con ella
digamos entonces que esta es nuestra
onda van caminando por el muelle se
detienen en este punto y el lugar justo
frente a ustedes es en donde esta onda
tiene su altura máxima y uno
a la derecha de ustedes el nivel del
agua es 0 2 metros a la derecha de
ustedes el nivel del agua llega a los
menos 3 qué significa esto de menos 3
significa que si este fuera un día
tranquilo y no hubiera ningún tipo de
onda
wola en el agua tendríamos un océano
plana o lago o lo que estemos viendo
pero si hay ondas u olas este nivel de
agua puede estar por encima de esta
posición o puede estar por debajo de
esta posición digamos que esta posición
cuando el agua está tranquila y sin
moverse le llamaremos posición 0 así que
grafica mos esto y nos queda este
resultado que realmente solo es una
imagen estática ya que esta posición
vertical con respecto a esta posición
horizontal es solamente una imagen en
otras palabras puedo llenar todo esto
con agua y decir ah bueno así es como
luce el agua en este momento del tiempo
pero si viéramos lo que hace el agua
pues se va a estar moviendo
hacia la costa de esta manera así que
nuestra gráfica es una imagen estática
de cómo luce el agua en cierto momento
del tiempo y cómo va a ser nuestra
ecuación pues será una ecuación de la
posición vertical de la onda que al
menos sea una función de la posición así
que esta es una función no es una
multiplicación esta debe ser una función
de la posición de manera que tenga yo
una función en donde pueda colocar
cualquier valor de la posición
horizontal digamos x igual a cero y me
debe dar como resultado este valor
máximo de aquí que es de tres metros por
lo que esta ecuación de onda debe
entregarme un 3 cada que yo le ponga x
igual a 0 y cuando ponga x igual a 1
deberá darle como resultado 0 así que me
debe dar un valor de 0 que es esta
altura y si yo pusiera como valor en x 6
metros
esta función me debería dar como
resultado un menos 3 que es esta altura
de acá así que no importa qué valor de x
yo aquí la función me debe dar el valor
exacto de la altura de la onda en esa
posición como se va a ver esta ecuación
pues vamos a tratar de encontrarla vamos
a encontrar a que es igual de equis pues
no debe ser mayor que 3 o menor que
menos 3 ya esto le llamamos la amplitud
si ésta es mi amplitud a mi función no
debe ser mayor que esta amplitud en este
caso mi amplitud es de 3 vamos a ponerlo
de forma general por lo que usamos la
literal como amplitud y que esto me
pueda funcionar para cualquier onda vean
la forma que tiene es como la de un seno
o un coseno cual es en particular este
bueno cuando x es igual a cero tenemos
el valor máximo esto se parece más a una
gráfica de un coseno ya que el coseno de
cero inicia con el valor máximo
así que decimos que este es el coseno de
algo que va a estar aquí quizás nos
veamos tentados de escribir simplemente
x
pero no nos va a funcionar si yo
escribiera x aquí esta fórmula no sería
lo suficientemente general como para
describir cualquier onda ya que si yo
aquí pongo solamente x el consell o de
equis se va a reiniciar cada dos pies
cada vez que todo lo que se encuentra
aquí adentro es igual a dos pi se va a
reiniciar el coseno pero vean este
coseno de aquí se reinicia cada cuatro
metros y quizá otra onda se reinicie
cada ocho metros y quizá otra onda se
reinicie a una distancia diferente
necesito una forma de especificar aquí
qué tan lejos debemos viajar en la
dirección x para que se reinicie la onda
x solita no lo va a hacer ya que si
pongo x aquí mi onda siempre se va a
reiniciar cuando llegue a 2000 cuando x
sea igual a 2 pi
así que lo que voy a hacer es hacer lo
mismo que hicimos para los osciladores
armónicos simples aquí digo que esto es
2 pin
y lo divido entre no el periodo por el
tiempo ya que esto no es una función del
tiempo al menos no aún aquí no es una
función del tiempo sino una función de x
así que aquí no pondríamos el periodo no
es el tiempo que le tarda a esta onda
reiniciarse de hecho es la distancia que
tiene que recorrer esta onda para
reiniciarse en otras palabras lo que
llamamos longitud de onda por lo que la
distancia entre dos picos que llamamos
longitud de onda y la representamos con
la letra griega lambda es la distancia
que le lleva a una onda reiniciarse y es
entre lo que vamos a dividir esto esto
tiene unidades de metros y después
multiplicamos todo esto por equis de
esta manera si yo comienzo con x igual a
cero el coseno comienza con un máximo y
aquí voy a tener tres si yo digo que me
x ha recorrido todo el camino de una
longitud de onda
que en este caso es de 4 metros ya que
recorrí estos 4 metros que es mi
longitud de onda y pongo este valor en
la función esta lambda en lugar de la
equis pues se va a cancelar con la
lambda que está dividiendo y me va a
quedar 2 pi y en este punto el coste no
se va a reiniciar una vez que todo el
argumento es igual a 2 espn el coche no
se va a reiniciar y es lo que pasa con
esta onda se va a reiniciar cada 4
metros cada longitud de onda recorre
esta longitud de onda y se vuelve a
reiniciar otra longitud de onda y se
reinicia y como aplicamos esta ecuación
de onda para esta onda en particular
pues vamos a tomarlo aquí aquí ya
tenemos el coche no lo cual está bien
porque corresponde a esta gráfica
podrían usarse no si su gráfica
comenzará en este punto y aumentará a
partir de ahí pero aquí comenzamos en el
máximo así que usamos coseno y nuestra
amplitud ya no es a va a ser igual atrás
nuestra agua alcanza la altura de tres
metros por encima del nivel de
equilibrio de la misma
dejamos el coseno aquí también el 2 pin
pero la lambda la sustituimos por la
longitud de onda de este ejemplo nuestra
longitud de onda que es la distancia de
pico a pico es de 4 metros o también la
pueden medir de valle a valle o de
mínimo a mínimo esta distancia también
es de 4 metros
es así como medimos la longitud de onda
y que pongo en lugar de la equis no la
sustituyó porque ésta es una función de
x es decir puedo poner valores en x y
saben que vamos a hacerlo vamos a
comprobar si esta función realmente nos
sirve vamos a comprobar si esta función
es correcta recordamos que esta función
nos dice dependiendo del valor de x cuál
es la altura de esta onda en esa
posición así que vamos a probar si esto
funciona aquí en lugar de la equis
ponemos el cero y para cero que el
resultado me va a dar esta función
pues me dice que el coseno de todo esto
que es 0 yo sé que el coseno de 0 es 1
por lo que toda esta función va a ser
igual a 3 metros cuando x sea igual a 0
lo que es cierto la altura de esta
gráfica cuando x es igual a 0 es de 3
metros así que esta función a probemos
otra ahora digamos que la posición
horizontal es de 2 metros sí aquí pongo
2 metros me va a quedar aquí 3 metros
por el coseno 2 x 2 es 44 entre 4 es 1
por lo que aquí tengo el coseno de pi y
el coseno de ti es menos 1 por lo que
aquí voy a tener menos 3 lo que es
cierto la altura de esta onda en los dos
metros es de menos 3 metros por lo que
esta fórmula no se está dando la
posición de la onda en cualquier momento
en cualquier lugar lo que está bastante
bien sin embargo quizás ustedes ya se
dieron cuenta de un problema me puedan
decir a ver un momento esto está muy
bien pero esto es para un instante del
tiempo
esta onda se está moviendo recuerden que
toda esta onda se dirige a la costa así
que en un momento particular del tiempo
esta ecuación nos puede dar la posición
o la altura de esta onda en cierto lugar
pero si espero un momento ya todo esto
no me va a funcionar porque mi onda se
movió ahora cuando la posición es igual
a 2 pues mi altura ya no va a ser menos
3 y cuando x es igual a 0 la altura
tampoco va a ser de 3 solo va a llegar
hasta acá ahora que hacemos como
describimos esta onda que se está
moviendo hacia la derecha con una sola
ecuación no está tan difícil como
podrían imaginarse vamos a quitar esto y
vamos a complementar la función que ya
encontramos aquí ya que lo que necesito
es una ecuación de onda que no sea
solamente una función de x sino también
una función del tiempo así que esta
función de aquí no solo es una función
con respecto a x sino que también tiene
que ser una función del tiempo de manera
que yo pueda poner
cualquier posición y cualquier momento
en el tiempo y me dirá cuál es el valor
de la altura de esta onda como encuentro
la dependencia del tiempo aquí
bueno recuerden que si agregamos una
constante de fase aquí
recuerden si sumamos un número aquí
adentro en el argumento del coseno va a
desplazar a la onda de hecho si
agregamos una constante nos va a
desplazar nuestra onda hacia la
izquierda y como nuestra onda se mueve a
la derecha no queremos agregar una
constante de fase vamos a restar una
constante así que vamos a restar cierta
cantidad y así nuestra onda se va a
desplazar hacia la derecha pero no me va
a servir poner aquí simplemente una
constante tal cual ya que las olas en la
playa no es que se muevan un momento
hacia la derecha y se detengan se siguen
moviendo todo el tiempo por lo que
necesitamos una onda que continúe
desplazándose y quizá ustedes ya se
dieron cuenta de que a lo mejor
aquí nos conviene poner esta constante
de desplazamiento como función del
tiempo de esta forma conforme aumenta el
tiempo la onda continuará desplazándose
cada vez más si este término del cambio
de fase aumenta cada vez que aumenta el
tiempo nuestra onda va a continuar
desfasando pse y desplazándose hacia la
derecha y así tendremos una ecuación que
representa una onda que se está moviendo
que es lo que vamos a poner aquí y quizá
piensen que esto va a ser complicado
pero no lo es tanto ya que como la
longitud de onda es la distancia que le
lleva a esta onda reiniciarse tenemos
algo llamado periodo que representamos
con la letra t mayúscula y el periodo es
el tiempo que les lleva a esta onda
reiniciarse si yo espero todo un periodo
esta onda se va a mover de tal manera
que va a llegar al punto en donde no
podremos darnos cuenta de que se movió
en donde luce exactamente igual
vamos a verlo así digamos que esta es
nuestra onda en el agua y tomo esta onda
y la
nuevo todo un periodo la onda habrá
llegado justo a donde estaba cuando
comenzó esta onda se está moviendo hacia
la costa
ustedes cierran los ojos durante todo un
periodo y cuando los vuelven a abrir la
onda luce exactamente igual así que
vamos a usar este hecho aquí necesitamos
que esta función se reinicie no
solamente después de una longitud de
onda sino que también se reinicie
después de un período como representamos
eso pues hacemos exactamente lo mismo
aquí no puedo poner directamente el
tiempo lo que voy a hacer es poner dos
pi entre el periodo de mayúscula y luego
lo multiplicó por el tiempo
de esta forma igual que cada vez que x
alcanza una longitud de onda
cada vez que caminamos una longitud de
onda en el muelle vemos la misma altura
ya que esto se vuelve dos pi cada vez
que esperamos un periodo completo esto
se vuelve dos pi y todo esto se va a
reiniciar otra vez y esta es la ecuación
de la onda y creo que podríamos hacerla
un poco más general este coche no pudo
haber
quizás nos encontremos con alguna onda
que se describa mejor con un seno que
comience aquí en cero y vaya aumentando
conforme aumenta la distancia y el
negativo recuerden que este negativo
hace que esta onda se desplace hacia la
derecha y podríamos usar positivo o
negativo dependiendo de hacia qué lado
se esté desplazando la onda a la derecha
con el negativo o hacia la izquierda con
el positivo un signo positivo aquí
describe una onda que se está moviendo
hacia la izquierda y un signo negativo
hacia la derecha y técnicamente hablando
podríamos hacer esto un poco más general
agregando otra constante de fase que va
hacia la derecha si lo agregamos podemos
incluir casos que sean un poco extraños
como por ejemplo nuestra onda puede
comenzar aquí en donde no comienza ni
como xenon y como coseno y para
expresarla tenemos que desplazar la un
poquito pero en nuestro caso no tenemos
que preocuparnos por esto ya que comenzó
en un máximo pero es
no tener esta constante de fase y esta
es nuestra ecuación de la onda es lo que
queríamos una función de la posición y
el tiempo que nos da la altura de la
onda para cualquier posición horizontal
equis y para cualquier tiempo t así que
vamos a aplicar esta fórmula para
nuestra onda particular que tenemos aquí
vamos a quitar esto ya que fue la
expresión para encontrar la altura
solamente como función de la posición y
en un momento del tiempo quizá esta
imagen que tomamos de la onda fue en un
momento que llamaremos de igual a cero
segundos
así que cuando te dé igual a cero
segundos tomamos esta imagen así luce
esta onda y esta es la función que
describe a esta onda en este momento del
tiempo pero la podemos mejorar ahora
podemos describirla para cualquier
posición x en cualquier momento te vamos
a hacer lo cual es la amplitud
es fácil sigue siendo 3 la onda nunca va
a ser más alta que tres metros y tampoco
va a estar más abajo de menos tres
metros por lo que nuestra amplitud sigue
siendo tres metros y en x igual a cero y
t igual a cero nuestra gráfica comienza
en un máximo así que queremos seguir
usando coseno llegamos aquí 2 por x
sobre lambda y lambda sigue siendo
holanda siguen siendo 4 metros ya que le
lleva 4 metros a esta gráfica para
reiniciarse tendríamos que caminar 4
metros sobre el muelle para ver que se
reinicia esta gráfica aunque no
realmente tendríamos que correr muy
rápido para hacer esto ya que la onda se
va a estar moviendo conforme nosotros
caminemos así que digamos que si ustedes
están en cero y un amigo de ustedes está
a 4 metros ambos verán la misma altura
ya que la onda se reinicia cada cuatro
metros aquí queremos que sea positivo o
negativo pues como se está moviendo a la
derecha va a ser negativo
aquí no voy a necesitar el término de
cambio de fase porque esto inicia en un
coseno perfecto y no en una función
extraña en el medio y lo único que falta
es ver qué es lo que voy a poner en el
lugar del periodo así que voy a
necesitar una pieza más de información
si me dijeran el periodo no tendría
problema pero a veces hay preguntas
capciosas quizás les digan que esta onda
se está desplazando a la derecha a 0.5
metros por segundo
digamos que esta es la rapidez de la
onda y les piden escribir una ecuación
de la onda que describa a esta onda en
espacio y en tiempo y ustedes sabían
esto pero entonces llegan a este punto y
se preguntan cómo encuentro el periodo
pues tenemos que usar el hecho de que si
recuerdan la velocidad de una onda pues
recuerden que la rapidez de una onda es
igual a la longitud de la onda por la
frecuencia del tiempo o la pueden
escribir como la longitud de la onda
entre el periodo y ahora despejamos el
período
el periodo de esta onda si me dan la
rapidez y la longitud de la onda el
periodo de esta onda va a ser igual a la
longitud de la onda dividida entre la
rapidez nuestra longitud de onda es de 4
metros y nuestra rapidez es de punto 5
metros por segundo lo que nos da un
periodo de 8 segundos por lo que tenemos
que poner 8 segundos aquí en lugar del
periodo y ahora si esta es mi ecuación
para esta onda y ahora si esta es mi
ecuación para esta onda y esta ecuación
es genial me describe la altura de la
onda para cualquier posición x y
cualquier tiempo t en otras palabras
aquí puedo poner 3 metros en lugar de la
equis y 5.2 segundos en lugar de la t y
medir a la altura de esta onda a los 3
metros en el tiempo 5.2 segundos a los
5.2 segundos lo que es bastante genial
en resumen esta es la ecuación de la
onda que describe la altura de la onda
para cualquier posición x
usamos el signo negativo si la onda se
mueve hacia la derecha y el signo
positivo si nuestra onda se mueve hacia
la izquierda